Born a slave,
he rose to become a prominence abolitionist,
statesmen,
author and respected figure around the world the most photographed
african-american of the 19th century.
He was also a recognizable figure even as his very identity put him at risk for
much of his life.
Frederick Douglass story is one of perseverance,
intellects,
and then an unending desire for freedom and justice.
Frederick Douglas wasn't born with that name,
noisy born on the day that he later adopted as his best date of birth.
He was christened Frederick Augustus,
Washington Bailey.
The date he was born has been lost to history.
Later in life.
You decided that February the 14th would be the day on which he marked his
entrance into the wells.
He said,
I have no accurate knowledge of my age,
never having seen any authentic record containing this is what he wrote in a
narrative of the life of Frederick Douglass.
We do know though that Douglass was born into slavery in Marilyn's likely the
son of a union between his mother and that owner,
Douglass.
His mother was known for her intelligence and is widely considered to be the
only slave who could read or write in the area of Maryland's where she lived,
but was never really got to know his mother.
It was common for infants born to slaves to be separated from their mothers.
Soon after birth.
Taking care of children took up energy and time that the younger women could use
to doing hard work on the farm or the plantation.
Older women who weren't able to do such physical neighbor could take care of
children and slave masters wouldn't see a drop in productivity.
So Douglas,
like many slaves,
he grew up without his mother.
He was sent to live with his grandmother that he bailey.
She was also the caretaker for 12 other children don't miss.
His mother was enslaved at a different plantation here.
And you saw how a handful of times before he was removed from his grandmother's
house at around age seven,
Douglas was separated from the family that he knew he was taken from his
grandmother's home and was sent to y plantation plantation.
He joined a thousand other slaves spread across 20 farms owned bite master Lloyd
Douglas.
He didn't work in the fields.
He was still young and so he didn't go out.
Instead,
you cared for the families,
cows and tended to the houses garden and it's yacht.
It was while he was at this farm that his mother died and then once again,
ductless was operated as a slave.
Douglass was forced to move and serve the winds of his masters.
This time he was sent to Baltimore to the family of Hugh old here.
Douglas followed in his mother's footsteps.
He learns to read and write is journey to literacy.
It started when Sophia,
old Hugh's wife again teaching him the lessons of the alphabet.
It was unusual for a slave owner.
It's takes so much interest in the education of a safe and he did not like that.
His wife was doing site plus all sorts that have slaves,
could read and write so they would be more likely to want their freedom and more
likely to seek it out.
Douglas called all those arguments against literacy.
His first decidedly anti slavery lecture.
Unfortunately,
Sophia came around to her husband's way of thinking and Douglas is tutoring
sessions.
They came to an end,
but douglass believed that once you learn to read,
you will be forever free,
and so he kept that name.
He taught himself to read,
grabbing any publication that had words on it.
Newspapers and political pamphlets joins books in his collection,
and Douglas began to learn much more than how to read.
He was learning about the events of the country and the rest of the world.
Among the publications he devoured was the Colombian or race.
At this book was an 18th century unfollow gig that was used as a literacy
teaching tool in classrooms for Douglas.
Though the book offered more than just a lesson in reading and writing,
it gave him an insight into ideas about freedom.
It's about human rights was he didn't want to keep the power of literacy to
himself.
Though he started teaching other slaves from nearby plantations to read during
Sunday school using the New Testament's,
dozens of slaves would show up each week to learn.
Amazingly just went unnoticed for nearly six months,
but when it was discovered that Douglas was teaching fellow slaves to read and
write,
the slave owners were beside themselves with anger.
One Sunday while Douglas was teaching ve fuming owners bust into the makeshift
school,
they were intense that they're slaves would not learn to read and write,
and they use violence to get that point across.
They used stones and clubs to ends that Sunday meeting and to end Dr says
teaching for the time.
Being.
Douglas was still a teenager when this happened,
since he was already beginning to make his mark on the world.
By the time Douglas had his teens,
he had also been moved from owner to owner and plantation to plantation.
Several times in his late teens,
Douglas were sent to be a slave for Edward Coby,
coby subjected to violence regularly beating and whipping him and his book,
my bondage and my freedom.
Douglas entitles the chapter devoted to his time on covese plantation as Colby,
the Negro breaker.
He rides if the beatings,
he sustained it covese hands.
I had not been in his possession three whole days before.
You subjected me to almost brutal chastisements onto his heavy blows.
Blood flowed freely and Wales will left on my back as large as my middle finger.
The sores on my back from this flogging continued for weeks for they were kept
open by the rough and coarse cloth which I wore for shouting.
Eventually Douglass began to fight back.
He gave covey a taste of his own medicine,
and the man never tried to use violence to control douglas game,
Douglas Near.
He couldn't continue life as a slave beyond his own beliefs and desire for
freedom.
He had also met a woman who inspired him to seek his own freedom,
and Maria was a free black woman from Baltimore.
She not only inspire to douglass freedom,
but fell in love with him.
The two of them,
they later got married in 1836.
Douglas first attempted to escape from slavery.
When his plan was discovered,
he was thrown in jail,
return to his own head.
Douglas remained a slave for two more years before he able to make another
escape.
Attempts on September the third,
18,
38,
Douglas took the risk that he knew could either start his life as a free man or
end it altogether.
I felt assured that if I failed in this attempt to my case would be a hopeless
one.
It would seal my fate as a slave forever.
He later wrote he had obtained papers showing him to be a free man,
a risky move in and of itself.
The neighbors belonged to a black sailor and so douglas hats to act the part if
he wanted to be successful before leaving his master's property in Baltimore.
Doesn't this costumed himself in a red shirt,
black revamps and the sales hat while he disguised himself with his clothes.
The plan still had one big floor.
Douglas wasn't a great physical match for the description on the haters.
If an official stopped to closely consider the measurements and the description
is journey to freedom,
it would be over.
Douglas boarded a train to Philadelphia,
and as expected,
he faced an inspection when he was asked to show free papers.
Douglas handed over his sailors identification and said,
I never carry my free papers to see with me.
I have a paper with the American Eagle on us that will carry me around the
world.
The answer and the papers were enough for the conductor.
Douglas was free to stay on the train and to continue his journey,
but he still had to make it through slave states.
When he risked getting arrested after an anxious journey,
Douglas stepped off the train in New York and made his way to a group of
underground railroad activists.
He was in a free state,
but it was not a free man.
He was technically a fugitive,
so could still be arrested.
The danger was definitely not over for him yet.
Nevertheless,
he was ecstatic to simply be in one of these free states.
I've often been asked how I felt when first I found myself on free soil.
There is scarcity.
Anything in my experience about which I could not give a more satisfactory
answer and new world had opened upon me,
if life is more than breath ends,
the quick rounds of blood.
I lived more in one day and then a year of my slave life.
It was a time of Jonah's excitement,
which words can,
but team the describe the underground railroad activists provided them shelter
for a day and got words to his beloved Anna that he was free.
She made her way up for Baltimore and the two were married in New York.
Within days there a couple of world further north to Massachusetts where life
was somewhat safer for a fugitive slave that was still prejudice.
However,
in Douglas had to work hard to find even the menial jobs where you could earn a
living.
While in new Bedford.
Douglas became a licensed preacher.
Auntie taught Sunday school and served as church sexton.
They also became involved in the abolitionist movements.
Douglas was inspired by abolitionist.
William Lloyd Garrison and avidly read his newspaper,
the liberator.
The first time Douglas was asked to speak as an abolitionist meeting.
He was frightened.
He had been unexpectedly asked to give a speech at the Massachusetts antislavery
societies national convention.
Through his nervousness,
he gave an incredibly eloquent and thoughtful speech,
unlikely white abolitionists who gave most antislavery speeches.
Douglas could speak personally about the pain and the brutality of slavery,
douglass skill,
public speaking.
It was quickly noticed and he talks more and more at antislavery meetings and
soon he was a key part of the abolitionist movements.
At meetings,
he would tell his story and rouse crowds to the course.
In 18,
43,
he joins the American antislavery society to toward the midwestern United States
and speak about the importance of abolishing slavery.
They traveled for six months spreading their message,
and in doing so often putting themselves in danger.
This was two decades before the civil war and slavery supporters wanted to make
themselves heard.
They turns violence on some occasions,
and Douglas had his hands broken during one melly and Indiana Douglas didn't
just put his oratory skills to work for the abolitionist movement.
Though he also wrote his autobiography,
telling the story of what it was like to grow up and if a slave titled
Narrative,
the autobiography of Frederick Douglass,
the book was a huge success.
It had nine reprinting and was translated so that it can be sold in Europe as
well.
The success of the book that came with a cost,
though it attracted attention to Douglas and he was still not a free man in the
eyes of the law.
Instead of going into hiding in the United States,
though Douglas headed to Europe,
that he was safe from arrest and could continue spreading his message and
telling his story.
During a two year tour of England and Ireland,
he raised his profile both back home and in Europe.
Crowds came to see him speak and some twists.
His appeal that is European support it.
It's began raising money to buy his freedom in America.
Douglas was also impressed with Europe.
He was treated like a person.
They're unlike.
He wasn't home instead of a democratic governments.
I'm under a monarchical governments.
Instead of the bright blue skies of America,
I'm covered with a softer gray fog of the emerald aisle.
I breathe hands low.
The Chattel becomes a man I gave around in vain for one who will question my
equal humanity,
claimed me as a slave or offer me an insult.
I find myself regarded and treated at every turn with the kindness and deference
paid to white people,
and I go to church.
I'm met by no upturns,
nose and scornful lip to tell me we don't sell our niggas.
Yeah.
His supporters were successful in raising the funds to buy douglass his freedom,
and he was able to return to America,
to his wife,
and to the course of freeing the millions of slaves in the country.
He started publishing his own paper,
the North Star,
and also took up causes of freedom beyond the abolitionist movements.
He spoke at the women's rights,
Seneca falls convention calling for women to be granted the right to vote.
He also became active in cooling for the desegregation of schools.
This is a full century before Brown and board of education was decided by the
Supreme Court
because of his activism and this perpetual presence in the abolitionist and
other movements,
Douglas was a highly recognized figure in America when the civil war began
during the walk.
Douglas is a fierce advocate of allowing African Americans to fight for the
union.
A war undertaken and brazenly carried for the petrol enslavement of the colored
man calls logically and loudly for the colored men to help suppress it.
Douglas even have the ear of Abraham Lincoln and was able to speak to the
president about his views on African American troops.
He used his publications and speeches to call for the inclusion of African
Americans in the army for two years.
He kept working on this issue.
In 18,
63,
lincoln issued the emancipation proclamation as African Americans were free to
join the army.
Douglas and his family were ready to have a son signed up to fight.
Under third became active in recruitments.
Douglas himself shifted his message from encouraging the inclusion of African
Americans in the military to encouraging African Americans to sign up to fight.
When time sample Carson and shall fall upon our national tragedy than hillsides
and valleys,
johnny the red and with the bloods nor Weisen with the bones of Kensington and
countrymen who have fallen in the sanguinary ans wicked strife.
When grim massaged war has moved his wrinkled front and our country,
you shall have regained its normal condition as a leader of nations in the
occupation and blessings of peace and history shall record the names of heroes
and martyrs who bravely answered the call of patriotism and liberty against
traitors thieves and assassins it.
Nobody said this in the long list of glory composed of men,
of all nations,
there appears the name of no colored man.
When the civil war ended,
slavery was outlawed.
Douglas did not step away from public life.
He believed that was still much work to be done in the fight for freedom.
He was appointed president if the Freedman's bank,
which helped promote economic development in the newly free African American
communities and also continued speaking around the country and was active in
supporting ulysses s grant 18,
68 campaign for the presidency.
Then in 18,
72,
douglas was nominated as Victoria woodhull,
his vice presidential running mate.
He didn't even know it had been nominated.
He didn't seek it out,
but the equal rights party,
but in one of the tickets nonetheless,
it wouldn't be as lost appearance in a presidential race.
In 18,
88,
he became the first African American to receive a vote for presidents as a major
party's convention.
His fame and his outspoken activism still made him a target for sinister
activities.
However,
the same year he was nominated as a vice presidential candidate.
His family's New York home was targeted by an arsonist.
The family was safe,
but the far show that he nor his African-american Bretheran was still not safe
from violence even years after the civil war and ended
Douglas spent the last two decades of his life in Washington dc where he served
as a United States marshal.
We have an appointment from President Hayes.
He and Anna lived in a home called Cedar Hill.
And,
uh,
his first love and his inspiration for his escape from slavery died in 18.
80 two.
Douglas remarried this time to a much younger white women.
It's children were upset and this was his new wife's family.
During the 18 eighties,
he continued traveling both the country and the world,
giving speeches on a number of political issues.
He also kept writing and issued a new edition of his autobiography and 80 slash
81.
The life and times of Frederick Douglass was his third book.
It also published my bondage and my freedom in 1855.
The political appointments kept coming to.
He said often diplomatic positions as recorder of deeds for DC into commission
now,
roughly welds Colombian exposition.
Douglas was speaking and crusading for rice right until the end of his life in
1995,
he gave a speech at the national convention of Women in DC.
He was incredibly well received,
but it was the last speech he would ever give.
Shortly after the speech,
he had a heart attack and passed away.
He was 77 years old.
Thousands paid their respects to this funeral in DC and Dr [inaudible] body was
then returned to Rochester,
New York,
where he was buried next to Anna Frederick Douglass risked his life for freedom.
Not so many when he escaped from slavery,
but every time he put himself out there as a public figure,
advocating for an end to slavery,
the right to vote and civil rights for all.
We're going to leave you today with some of his own powerful words where justice
is denied,
where poverty is enforced,
where ignorance prevails ends,
where any one class is made to feel that society is an organized conspiracy to
oppress rob and degrade them.
Neither persons nor property will be safe.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now,
one is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
suffering the archive over there on the race and as always,
thank you for it.